safety standards are on the agenda this
month as ministers responsible for
competitiveness in the eu meet in
brussels
unions looking to modernize safety
requirements for personal protection
equipment and devices using cables for
transport like cable cars and chair
lifts the aims to strengthen controls
without placing a heavy burden or costs
on industry
smart regulation and the management of
customs risks to ease trade are on the
agenda too
ministers will also try to agree on a
broad outline for reform of the travel
package directive the arrival of online
travel services has changed the way the
sector operates and the council wants to
make sure the protection for travelers
is kept up to date
the reform would also aim to cut costs
and red tape to small and medium
enterprises which make up much of the
travel sector
and as the european space agency sets a
world first from its rosetta spacecraft
landing a probe on a comet 500 million
kilometers from earth the ministers will
debate the challenges and direction that
eu space policy should take in the
future
italian astronaut luca parmitano will
share his experience on the
international space station with the
council